all right so first of all a wonderful
good morning and indeed it is still the
morning session at 11:40 that's I
believe the most unfortunate time slot
I've ever been to because at this point
in time everybody's thinking about the
lunch break now I've done the most the
most severe error any speaker can do
I've mentioned
lunch now nobody listening listen to me
anymore anyway but let's talk a little
bit about design patterns and some
misconceptions that I found out
about so first give me a one minute 30
seconds to quickly introduce myself my
name is CLA elberger and I'm doing a lot
of C trainings consultancy Etc and I had
talk a lot about design patterns I've
even a written book about design
patterns because from my point of view
this is a totally underrepresented Topic
in the community it may be old but I do
not think that it's out of date or uh
not important
anymore so let's talk a NE about design
patterns but perhaps in this talk with a
special
twist it's primarily about terminology
because I I've seen the terms the names
of design P used for various uh things
not necessarily the right things okay
before we now go into the terminology
quick reminder of what is a design
pattern so design pattern first of all
has a name now for this talk actually is
the primary thing that I want to talk
about because this name already has a
lot of weight it carries meaning it
communicates an intention now if I name
a design pattern you should already have
pretty good idea what I'm talking about
design patterns generally aim at
reducing
dependencies therefore help us to manage
um our software structure our software
and I usually do this by providing some
sort of abstraction
some sort of abstraction doesn't have to
be a base class it's perfectly okay to
just have a pointer function poter
included base classes of course
templates standard functions stood
variant all of this stuff yeah any way
to provide an
abstraction and last but not least
design patterns are not invented they're
usually discovered which is a pretty
interesting detail in the end um so
usually you see that something's working
for a couple of years
perhaps even see this in many places um
working and so then you have found and
discovered design
pattern so now for me today it's primly
about the
name because terminology indeed matters
terminology matters because this is the
way we communicate about
code and so a quote from K Lal um that
from my point of view expresses exactly
why we have patterns in in the
languages the use of design patterns
provides us in our daily lives with
decisive speed advantages for
understanding complex structures this is
also why patterns found way into
software development years ago
consistently applied patterns help us
deal with the complexity of source
code so for that reason I actually hope
that when I use the term Builder I'll
you pretty much of the same idea
same realize the same
intention also if I use the term Factory
method I hope that all of you have
pretty much the same idea yeah that when
I say this um we communicate about the
same thing when I say bridge I also hope
that you have the same idea in mind the
same dependency structure and last but
not least um when I say design pattern I
also hope that we pretty much
communicate about the same
thing and that is the four terms that
today I want to talk about a little
bit so let's start with Builder indeed
and I admit that initially when I
planned this talk I actually didn't
think about this but I changed my mind
when couple of months ago somebody
posted at LinkedIn a kind of a nice
overview of design patterns now the 18
18 of the most commonly used design
patterns a quick reminder to some extent
you see in top it also mentioned the
Builder design
pattern then somebody in this um thread
asked what is your favorite design
pattern and many people replied well 44
it's a reasonable number and I was super
surprised to find that many many people
replied with
Builder I was surprised because I don't
see a lot of Builders nowadays so I was
curious and I was
asking many people here state that their
favorite bu pattern is the Builder
pattern let makes me curious which
program language you use and which
Builder do you refer to a the GF Builder
pattern or B Joshua bl's Builder
pattern unfortunately you see only five
people replied but at least these five
answers consistently said that actually
they were thinking about the B josa bl's
Builder
pattern so if you've not heard about
this this is a pattern that was first
described in the Effective Java book
many many years
ago now I don't want to present Java
code so I translated this into modern
C++ to give you a little bit of an
example so imagine we have some class
and some class very quickly uh
translates into widget so we have a
widget with a Constructor that takes a
lot of parameters a lot of them so it
doesn't have to be five could be even
more and of course immediately you see
that this style is already questionable
many many integers that could be
confused and uh
switched it's a dangerous kind of
interface but also many of these values
might have
defaults so I might assume X and Y to be
Zero by default but I just cannot omit
them because they're F the first two
parameters so how do I approach this
problem in a safe way such that this
interface is easy to use correctly and
hard to use incorrectly
well the first step definitely should
always be even independent of this uh
pattern is to have strong types for
these parameters so the exposition might
be represented with the Type X PA the Y
position with that y pass with height
title etc etc it definitely is a first
step totally independent of anything
that follows good now with this we could
actually indeed very easily overload the
Constructor could have 10 different
Constructors that just Express all the
variations of parameters that we have
okay not
particularly yeah um
convenient so now that we have these
strong types what we can provide are set
functions so set functions for the X
pause the Y pause etc etc note in
particular that these functions are all
called set not set xport set YP no no
all of them are called set so we consist
using function overloading here and that
is the key now the constru
is now replaced with a very generic
Constructor that takes just
arguments veric template
parameters these arguments are all moved
forwarded whatever into the set function
and today we can very easily and
conveniently do this by means of fold
Expressions very
nice all of these arguments are given to
set which of course because of the
strong types calls the right set
function that is
nice super convenient on the one hand
side and it suddenly enables us to um
provide an interface that pretty much
cannot be
misused so in the in the main function
we can uh pretty much pass all the
parameters but suddenly we have the
ability just to Mid a view the ones that
we do not want to specify the ones where
we use want to use a default and also
the order suddenly doesn't matter we can
first provide with orx pass or or this
way nice really nice pretty cool amazing
way to write a Constructor that deals
with a lot of
defaults and this is now what a lot of
people think about when they think about
Builder and if somebody asks a question
what is your favorite design pattern
this is what they think
about unfortunately this is not really
what it is this is not a design
pattern so to just go to the other
pattern the gang of four design pattern
here's a short quick reminder of what
the gang of four says about
this separate the construction of a
complex object from its representation
so that the same construction process
can create different
representations so of course in this
book published in
1994 they use a an inheritance hierarchy
which was just the thing of the time
yeah this was uh the '90s Aron program
was all the
but there's one thing about this picture
this is why I used it which makes it
clear that this is different implicitly
there is an architectural boundary in
the middle so I have a clear separation
between two levels of programming the
abstract part on top and the more
concrete part at the bottom and so there
is definitely an inversion of
dependencies happening I communicate by
means of this um this inheritance
hierarchy good
good and so yes there are two different
Builders there's first the gang of four
design pattern Builder design pattern
and then as josha Block's Builder
pattern but I would Clearly say that
josha block Builder is not a design
pattern don't get me wrong it's super
valuable and absolutely cool I would use
it too but it's not a design pattern
there is no architectural
boundary I do not really separate
between two levels of code that's not
the
intention and so I'm definitely also not
focused on reducing or inverting
dependencies it's just a very useful and
very convenient implementation
detail but this is what it is I would
say that it's super similar to an API
pattern called fluent
interface if youve not heard about this
please check it out at Wikipedia super
simple to find because it is pretty a
pretty PR common thing to to write
interfaces perhaps not so much in C++ I
don't know other languages use this more
often but this is pretty much an ability
gives you the ability to write fluent
code yeah things that you can pretty
much read like it's like writing
sentences in code and so
comprehensibility and usability of
course should improve good stuff just
not a design
pattern so please don't confuse josha
bl's Builder pattern with a G of four
Builder pattern the two different things
which UNT have the same name which of
course now brings me back to the terms
it's a little difficult nowadays to talk
about Builder now somebody ask what is
your favorite design pattern some people
say Builder and these two people might
have very different things in mind
that's unfortunate so if you today use
the term Builder from now on it might
might not be a bad idea to be a little
more specific do you talk about the G
Builder G of four or do you talk about
block
Spiller yeah both have their values but
both are superb they're just very
different
things all right so terms matter else we
are talking about two completely
different
things which brings me to a second term
a term that oh my I've seen used so
arbitrarily in so many blogs books even
um that by now I I believe nobody really
knows what a factory method is
anymore so quick example some toy
example we want to draw
shapes so to get started I first have a
vector of uni pointers of shape and of
course it doesn't have to be but that's
the traditional thing the classic thing
again and I previ this with shapes it's
more convenient then there is a function
that allows me to draw all the shapes
that's good yeah convenient again but
then I have a function to read shapes
from Json I pass a string the file name
and I get all the shapes everything
that's stored in the Jason file and then
in the main function I read the shapes
from Jason and I draw
them
cool now my major point of interest is
the read shapes from Json
function now this function creates all
the shapes and so it creates something
it's it's a factory function in L
however and as I said also in blocks Etc
very often this is considered to be an
example for the factory method design
pattern we create
something
no unfortunately
no a creation function is not
automatically a factory method or not
even a design pattern again don't get me
wrong it's a valuable thing but it has
nothing to do with softer
design so again don't get me wrong this
definitely improves code without doubt
so it encapsulates this creation process
super valuable because now you can
change things in one place and that's
one function if a new kind of shape
enters the the picture you can do this
in one this one function you don't have
to do the all of the code base and so
you can control to do things in one
place fulfills kind of the SRP and draw
good
but again we have not really thought
about reducing any dependencies
so if it's not dependency related it's
probably not a design pattern it's
merely an implementation
detail but then what is a factory
method okay let's let's use this example
to just develop it into something where
we actually deal about talk about
dependencies so let's first introduce an
architectural boundary that's the the
the the first point the starting
point
but okay again we have high level
lowlevel this is terms that usually
confuse people so let's make it a little
a little more specific the upper code is
my
code and the lower code is your
code so you read shapes from Jason and
that's good for you
absolutely this is valuable for you but
I don't care about this at all that's a
little implementation detail on your
side of the architecture I don't have to
know this
but now let's let's make things more
interesting let's just argue or assume
that I want to create shipes too but I
don't really want to deal with the
details so in order to um give get an
example say I now need a create and draw
shapes function I want to create a
couple of shapes I want to draw them and
draw shapes is in my side
but not the read shapes from function uh
shapes from Json function that function
is on your
side now if I would call this actually
would totally break the architecture you
can use my code but I cannot use your
code so this definitely is uh not
working at all at this
point so
consequently I would have to take your
function I would have to be to become
the owner of fre shapes from
Jason but this makes both of us pretty
unhappy first
I now suddenly have to deal with all the
shapes suddenly I know about circles and
rectangles and squares and all these
things that I don't really care about
and you you cannot change my function
it's my function SLE you are no longer
in charge of the uh of the
details that's
bad however let's start to to
communicate let's start to design that
so our goal is that I can create shapes
when I need them but I definitely don't
want to depend on all the details that
that's your problem and you you actually
want to depend on the details but you
might not be so much concerned in when
and how to draw them all right so this
is where this Factory method design
pattern enters the
game as a quick reminder what does the
gang of for say about
this Define an interface for creating an
object but let's subclasses decide which
class to instantiate Vector method let
the class defer instantiation to
subclasses of course there certain
connotation here it talks about sub
classes which is very objectoriented but
again this is the time this is just what
the book does it primarily talks about
Define an interface for
creating and this is now what we
do so first of all you get your function
back I don't want to know that the
details okay but then in my create
shapes create and draw shapes I just
open up the world for your code by
introducing a function
pointer function poter such an archaic
thing okay doesn't have to but then you
totally lose the um the idea that it has
to be a base class so I take a function
poter to some function that creates
shapes and just use it my function
really I really don't care what it what
I get I can just use the stuff you on
the other hand okay and this is now an
example for the factory method design P
yes and note I point to the function
pointer I do not point to the function
below the function below is still just a
an implementation detail Factory
function the factor method is actually
just my function
pointer so you canot just pass your
function to um my code
and that's great yeah so suddenly I can
uh create shapes without having to know
the details good
stuff so again the core of this entire
idea is that there is an architectural
boundary somewhere in the
middle and that there is a dependency
inversion now I talked a lot about
dependencies I uh talked a lot about I
don't need to know this stuff that's
pretty much what the design patterns do
so just that some of you can sleep well
of course we could do this with a base
class sure we have a shapes Factory on
my side of the code with a virtual
create
function I take a say reference to the
shapes Factory uh in my function and you
could implement this of course however
you want to it's the same idea it's not
um something totally different it's not
suddenly um now suddenly a design
pattern so the takeaway is is that
factor method and Factor functions
function are two different terms which
unfortunately are mixed up so often the
problem is that in C++ we often talk
about methods but to just say it clearly
in C++ there are no methods now take a
in take a look at the index of the C++
standard the term method doesn't appear
there are no methods in C++ we have
functions everywhere and so Factor
method is kind of a special term which
indeed comes a little bit from the Java
world so this is actually something that
it's not just my idea this is something
that's even written at Wikipedia so if
you go to the English version Look for
Factory and then go to terminology then
indeed as the explicit statement
unfortunately this is not really visible
here the last sentence the general
concept of a factory is often confused
with a specific Factory method design
pattern two different things
unfortunately and
so remember that the term Factory is
heavily overloaded and that that factory
loan is not necessarily referred to this
Factory method design
pattern so distinguish between the
general idea of a factory function and
really you can use that term for
anything anything that creates something
is a factory function in the
end and distinguish to factory method
that's something that has a certain yeah
carries a certain meaning yeah we
somehow distinguish um um communicate
about how shapes are created I want to
do this but you know the details so
perhaps consider Factory method design
pattern a customizable Factory function
that might be a good good
translation all
right there's another term that I would
like to
address
Bridge aka the pimple idiom
I think when I say Bridge you already
have a pretty good idea but still allow
me to quickly give you a little bit of
an uh motivation so this time my
motivation are electric cars why well
because I not just say that in electric
cars things are changing a lot in
particular The Battery Technology is
changing a
lot so if you now consider this in terms
of a class some electric car class then
this class might have a data member
called battery of
course
however having this data member as a
concrete type might actually create a
lot of change indeed so whenever
something about battery changes users of
electric car will experience the change
will see this change and if the size of
battery for instance changes it's not
just some change it really is an ABI
break everything will have to be
recompiled
everything that uses electric
car so if this happens often this might
be a real
inconvenience and it might be something
that might not be even acceptable to to
people so what about what to do about
this well we could first of all again
introduce some abstraction some battery
okay battery is well a base class with
uh some functions say charge that that
should give you an
idea so then electric
car electric car does no longer um store
battery as a as a um concrete type but
as a pointer to base as an abstraction
and we might get this via the
Constructor okay then of course there
are many many different implementations
of battery battery gen one gen two gen
three yeah things change there's a lot
of of new
stuff and then in the electric car class
uh we would just get out battery that is
provided via the Constructor so electric
car takes some battery say battery gen
one and electric car does not change
again and again and again anymore good
so electric car itself becomes pretty AI
stable again this is well not exactly
the example but a very similar example
to what we see in blocks and books even
this is not a bridge unfortunately it
pretty much sounds like a bridge but it
is not and it is about this particular
parameter so we are injecting the
battery gen one into the electric car
class and yes you know the term for that
dependency injection not to be confused
with dependency inversion that's
something different but we inject the
battery and so this is usually given as
a as a a bridge
example but to say it clearly bridge is
never about dependency injection never
worse never will be that's not what
bridges are
about to show why let's indeed go into
the example that the gang of four in
their book give on their own so we don't
have to understand the complete example
just the the um the upper um setting
their example is about Windows so we
have different
Windows the windows however depend on
the
platform so we might be on Linux we
would use something different then on
Windows different than a ma on Mac OS so
in order to factor this out these
differences we introduce a window imp
yeah they call it imp not imple and this
thing has many many different
implementations yeah X window cute
window whatever is available
good
this is what they they uh write about
this particular
example consider the implementation of a
portable window obstruction and user
interface
toolkit clients should be able to create
a window without committing to a
concrete implementation only the window
implementation should depend on the
platform in which the application
runs so not my words their words but
pretty clear with without committing to
a concrete implementation yeah they
should not depend on the
platform the code example okay this is
really pretty much copy and paste from
their code example and and no this not
what we do today anymore please please
don't but just to to point it out in
code we have this window imp up here
that's the abstraction of different
kinds of
implementations some P viral function
whatever
and we have the window class this window
class has a window imp yes this is the
thing that you please do not copy now
the nowadays uni pointer is is not just
optional
anymore this window imp that is my
pointer to implementation now we
commonly call this pimple nowadays not
just imp that is my point at
implementation but this point at
implementation is not passed anywhere no
this is my personal private little thing
that nobody else needs to care about
problem about the example however is
that in the Constructor I'm given a view
and this view is another data
member but this view has nothing to do
with a bridge example it just happens to
be there because it probably feels a
little more realistic that's another
design pattern this is what we call the
strategy design
pattern and that's the difference yeah
kind of combined in this
example the Bridge pattern is not about
injection this is about hiding the
details as much as possible yeah you
don't care it's my concern the strategy
pattern on the other hand is very much
about dependence
injection this is exactly what this what
the point is you give me the view and I
don't need to
care so to just and of course note many
people then just call things imple and
then it's a bridge or pimple or whatever
the name of the data member make a
difference it's about how you provide
this this
imple so our car example in order to fix
that to really make it a bridge would
not have to do a lot the battery would
still be the same pretty
much um the electric car class however
would change a bit because silly in the
Constructor I would not accept an engine
anymore sorry a battery a battery
anymore that's my concern not yours yeah
I deal with battery then of course no
dependence injection then of course
there are still many
implementations yeah but these
implementations are chosen by the
electric car itself electric car creates
its own
engine and so if you create an electric
car somewhere in the um in the main
function for instance you just well give
it a name perhaps you give it some other
things that are a little more
superficial but you do not care about
batteries that's entirely a problem of
the electric car itself so that's a
bridge so the confusion probably comes a
little bit
from this really big
similarity this is the uml class diagram
that they gang of for users kind of I'm
I'm now using my example but this is
pretty much what it looks like yeah
there's a little box that says
bridge but if you then compare it to the
strategy design
pattern it looks alike it's the same uml
class diagram no difference at all
except for the little box that says
bridge and so it is easy to confuse it
is easy not to see the
difference but the difference becomes
visible if you really think about
dependencies so this is the dependency
structure
of of
bridge so on the left lower left the
electric car directly uses the
battery battery gen one and gen two and
gen uh gen three it directly uses that
so these two are on the same level of
the architecture they know each other
that's the
point strategy on the other hand moves
this bar gen one to a lower um level so
now the electric car is totally unaware
of a battery and requests a battery and
its Constructor please give me a battery
somebody else now takes care of that and
provides this and another level of the
architecture so again the difference is
an architectural
boundary all right
so please do not confuse bridon strategy
and if somebody in in some code example
explains
by dependence injection please just
rethink say okay it's a
strategy so use the term bridge when you
do referred to internal customization no
dependency
injection again that's the point of a
bridge and if there is a dependen
injection it's very likely a strategy
not necessarily but very likely in in
the example it definitely was so bridge
is about internal customization strategy
about external
customization
all right so again the term matters else
we talking about two totally different
things so which brings me
to term number
four the term design
pattern now sometimes submit talks about
design patterns in general and one of
the latest um reviews I get back
contained the following remark
I believe that object under programming
especially its theory is overestimated
C++ always at templates and now it also
has stood variant which makes most of
the use of inheritance
unnecessary so
the the opinion itself I feel is deeply
flawed but there's there's something
else now here as soon as you say design
pattern people think about
objectoriented programming it's like a
reaction it's like this is what it is so
design patterns equal object oriented
programming not really not really and
this is not
news some of you might have um might
know this book modern C++ design by
Andre alexes by the way is at this
conference and Andre is still mocking uh
the community by saying he invented mod
C++ because this book was published in
20 2001 so kind of 10 years before we
had uh C+ 11 with modern C++ okay Joker
side in this book he uses design
patterns it's in the subtitle but never
by means of a base class but very
consistently by means of templates at
the time he was torching compilers
everything was done in templates and I
think there was one compiler that comp
could compile his his
code so we have already learned that
it's not just about base classes so
strategy
I just picked on this one because this
is something quite quite useful to to uh
to talk about so this classic form is
often considered to be the one
implementation strategy is a base class
and we can provide things and nothing
could be farther from the truth there's
so many different ways to to do a
strategy and in fact the C+ standard
libr itself uses hundreds of strategies
inde hundreds of them so just a few
examples unique
pointer that's a class that all of us
know about and I think you are aware of
the fact that unic point actually has
two template parameters T and the
deleter T being the type that we deal
with and deleter being the thing that
cleans up
eventually now this deleter this is not
just some nice new idea this deleter is
actually a strategy
just in template
form dependency injection so we inject
the deleting Behavior into the uni
pointer class configure the uni
pointer that's a
strategy then St um um um stood Vector
the the um the container two template
parameters again we have the T and we
have
allocator and of course the allocator
it's not just some idea it allows me to
inject the allocation um mechanism now
it allows me to say uh to tell Vector
how to acquire memory it's a strategy
again nothing about a strategy in in
form of a template parameter in fact
pretty much all containers use a
strategy all over the place so hash said
here actually has three different
strategies then
algorithms
accumulate so I want to accumulate
meaning sum up all the numbers in this
Vector of integers 1 2 3 4 5 to
7 of course I would pass begin numbers
and numbers a zero okay and then I can
decide how to add things up okay I chose
the boring thing perhaps but stood
plus what is stood
plus well it's a
strategy it's a
strategy I inject the behavior for the
accumulation into accumulate I decide
how accumulate should do its work
accumulate doesn't care it will do its
job I can inject this
behavior
and next example generate so generate is
the algorithm that builds the vector
with numbers not in sense of it adds
numbers but it sets the the numbers
generate takes
a ah no not a strategy F Factory method
so now not every dependency injection
must be a strategy but this one this one
generates something and again it's a
template paramet that allows me to say
how the things which things are
created Factory
method and so
indeed generate could be written in so
many different ways of course the
standard way of doing things is um to
pass a template parameter um uh
generator and yes of course this is the
right way of doing things but it would
still be a factor method if I would um
do this in form of a function pointer
yeah okay the AR archaic thing but I
could do it if I wanted to so function
pointer still Factory method I could yes
of course also use a base class not
particularly um good idea in in the
context of dstl but generally it would
be a factory method so in form of a base
class and last one not least I could
Envision also that we pass a St function
again not a good idea s we have runtime
po but it it definitely is still Factory
method so it's not the how I implement
it it's what I want to express it's the
name it's the
term so my own quote design patterns
truly are everywhere every kind of
dependency inversion every kind of
dependency management all of these are
already designed patterns they are
everywhere we cannot work without
them
so please do not believe that design
patterns are objectoriented programming
now I believe they're one of the most
essential building blocks for successful
software development and as part of that
being such an essential building block
it definitely is about the terminology
so if we cannot talk about them because
we and misunderstand each other because
you have a different idea then of course
it doesn't work really well so please
realize that the terminology around
design patterns represent represents an
essential tool to deal with software
complexity and so to quote Cara
again the use of design patent provides
us in our daily lives with decisive
speed advantages for understanding
complex structures this is also why
patterns found the way into software
development years ago consistently
applied patterns help us to deal with
complexity of source code so and a such
I really think that terminology truly
matters so please keep these terms in
mind and uh use them
consistently thank you very
much so we definitely have time for a
few questions if there are
some
all right that was the capital M
okay one question wouldn't the um
example where you pass the generator
argument uh uh to the the argument of
the factory to the generator couldn't
you interpret that also as a
command and here we are again at so the
question was just to speak it out loud
again um couldn't this uh injection of a
pointer Etc be a command oh my this is
now something we could talk for hours
about yeah command is again one of these
patterns that looks exactly like
strategy and Factory they all look alike
some point so I would not fight over
which term it truly is doesn't matter
the most important point is to really
realize that there is some some
dependency management happening so if
you feel like it's a factory method and
if you call it this way no I called my
function point a factory method okay
then then you communicate what you want
to have in code if you call this command
okay then why not then you interpret
this as a command still gives me the
ability to do something yeah so okay I I
would argue it's a factory method but I
would not fight over
it just just to tease
um another comment I'd like to make if
if nobody has questions I don't want to
uh that maybe to to give you an
impression I wrote a patent book or
several patent books actually and the
first one was the second one after the
gang of four patent books so uh yeah and
and and I'm teaching that
for I forgot how maybe 30 years now and
I think we allowed to see the the title
of the book patn oriented architecture
which is
AA yeah um which is a
um again a classic yeah this is
something that everybody should have
taken a look at um maybe one comment I
gave a talk ages ago about design
patterns in modern C++ and uh still
using inheritance from time to time but
actually using a lot of the
customization points through template
parameters and that often turns around
the inheritance hierarchy on uh uh top
down so what you see the go pattern you
have the base abstraction and then uh
derived classes in if you if you use
template parameters you tend to have
uh then have the crtp pattern inside
where you more or less inherit from your
your parameter instead of uh uh going
the other way around yeah good comment
so maybe I should resurrect that talk
for next year why not I think as I said
in the beginning I think we are not
talking about this enough um talk about
the little details in the language
standards features but not so much about
how to design things the big picture all
right then you have an early lunch break
this is good I believe thank you very
much